conversation matters
the more that i do this and the more
tumultuous
society feels
i think that the only way forward is
conversation
my name is rich roll after writing my
best-selling book finding ultra
i launched a successful podcast where
i've had
the incredible opportunity to interview
hundreds of amazing human beings
truly some of the best and the brightest
through the thousand plus hours of
conversations with
amazing thought leaders doctors
olympians artists
and world changers one thing had become
clear the words of these individuals
have the power to change
the planet my goal with this new book
is to share the highlights of these
conversations with you i humbly present
my latest offering
voicing change a beautifully crafted
compendium
of my podcast featuring over 280 pages
of
carefully selected photos and excerpts
from podcast
conversations all presented in a
visually compelling format
as i reviewed these impactful
conversations and preparation for this
book
i was deeply moved by the wisdom these
guests shared there were gems i had
forgotten about
and even some i had simply not noticed
the first time around
i believe you will have a similar
reaction
whether you're new to the podcast or
have been with me since the beginning
voicing change is for you replete with
inspiration
and enriching wisdom voicing change
available for pre-order now
at richroll.com